YouTubers who abuse built-in support
systems to silence creators who are
critical of them are the worst of the
worst.
>> Are the worst of the worst, guys. Does
he keep that energy? I can't prove that,
guys, but it certainly seems like the
most likely explanation. The Oreo swept
for DMCA abuse. He's so dumb, bro. I
think he's And this fat, lying
>> [music]
>> knew. He knew and he covered it up. The
goal was always to find a way to become
the number one Ethan Klein ball washer.
Cut the Oreo segment. Let's take a look,
guys. Let's see. What does Keemstar have
to say about the Oreo?
Hasan [__] is a genuine douchebag,
extremely unintelligent, probably as
politically illiterate as me on most
things and I have and I literally know
nothing. A complete normie who doesn't
care about politics.
Nicholas DeOrio is the owner of a pair
of mid-sized commentary YouTube
channels. His following is somewhere
around 150,000 people and is known for
covering new online dramas and his
ultimate review segment.
>> I'm the host of Ultimate Review.
>> [music]
>> Nick has been involved in the commentary
genre for almost Dude, DeOrio fans
actually lose it if you even mention
Ultimate Review. It's so crazy, man.
He's like uh
he's like trained them into thinking
that like Ultimate Review didn't happen
or something. If if anyone even brings
up review, they're like, "What? I can't
believe they're bringing up review." So
most of a decade. He's been closely
associated with figures like Tommy C,
Turkey Tom, Willy Mac, and other
long-time contributors to online drama
coverage. He's not the biggest
>> Yeah, sorry. Let's make this totally
comprehensive because, you know, we know
that uh uh DeOrio and DeOrio fans like
pretending that
review is exactly what it sounds like.
So let's make this totally
comprehensive. Let's get this in here. I
feel like this is important. This is
part of the story here, really, isn't
it? So, review. A lot of people use this
term now, and it's pretty much what it
sounds like. People in commentary
reviewing allegations. The earliest
instance that I could actually find of
this term being used is Vaush talking
about how DGG have coined this term.
Yeah, so um Destiny's been doing this
it's sort of crassly being referred to
as the review, uh where he goes over
allegations. This was for the
MethodJosh, the the Twitch
review was coined because he would
review the allegation. And although it
originated with DGG, this guy, Chud
Logic, pretty much yoinked it and
popularized the term. With the Shawn
Head drama, we covered the um phase
review, as my community call it. There
was that a guy Mew got accused of some
allegations, so we looked at the that
and talked about that. Chud started
doing some really good numbers reviewing
allegations with his review segments.
>> [music]
>> And soon many drama content creators
decided to copy the format. The person
who I think saw the most popularity out
of reviewing rape allegations was
Nicholas Diiorio. Dude, I would love to
do a review of Chud Logic where we just
like live react to like
>> Thank you.
>> [clears throat]
>> By the way, guys, we're probably going
to do an ultimate review if not this
this weekend, maybe early next week. Uh
because we haven't done Savannah yet.
And I know it's kind of a dead topic for
everybody, but I'm going to talk about
Savannah because I'm malicious, okay?
Yesterday I had people over and they
were asking about what I do for a
living, and I told them that I do IT and
ultimate review, and there is no in
between, Chud. to, you know, my content
to be known more, but I don't want it to
become more well known because I was
assaulted.
>> This is like this E Thot for rape
connoisseurs, isn't it?
>> E Thot for rape connoisseurs. That's
exactly [laughter] what
But this is where the rewriting of
history starts. There There one time
where somebody Googled and read off my
Wikipedia. They're like, "He hosts the
show Ultimate Rape Review." And I go,
"Listen, okay? I can try to explain this
to you. I'm not going to. I swear to God
it's not what it sounds like."
>> [laughter]
>> It's exactly what it sounds like. There
are now these newcomer channels that I
don't think it's right to judge, but
they're claiming that Ultimate Rape
Review is a satirical name for a show,
and Nicholas DeOrio does not review
rapes. You don't have any valid reason
to criticize this on. Then he
characterizes these detractors as being
rape reviewers when they're not. And
hold on, hold on. We'll We'll get there.
If you know, you know. We'll get there.
So, of course, Nicholas DeOrio does not
do [__] rape reviews in the literal
sense. He uses that word in a very
internet speak manner, but I'm not
surprised that people would hear about
it and assume the worst.
>> No, no, he doesn't use it to mean sexual
assault. No, no, he uses rape to mean
sexual assault, actually.
After watching some of Nicholas DeOrio's
VODs over the past few months, I
recognize that Ultimate Rape Review is a
satirical name, and the segment
highlights how YouTube drama
consistently turns [music] other
people's trauma into content.
>> This is a factual inaccuracy. If you
ever want to make a claim like this,
just load up Filmot first, search a
couple terms, and see what you can find.
It's all right to get stuff wrong, but
to Princess Mantis and That's So Katie,
I think it would be good to make a
little retraction in your what have you
next video is. Just say, "I made this
claim about Nicholas DeOrio, and I was
wrong. It turns out Nicholas DeOrio
loves rape. And just a year or two ago,
he used to love to review rape
allegations on his show Ultimate Rape
Review." Oh, I noticed this a lowlife
disabled woman
uh says, "Oh, hey it's me. No rebuttal
and no retraction." Interesting. Uh
Sonic not pressing her because she's is
woman. I think we all know what's going
on there. Anyway, back to Keemstar's
video here. name, but he is
well-established, and he's seen as
somebody with credibility in these
circles. And part of that is because
historically, Nick has always positioned
himself as being somebody with
principles. He was always one of the
most outspoken creators about things
like targeting sponsors,
>> Attacking YouTube sponsors is generally
like a negative thing to do.
>> Attacking sponsors, doxing, like there's
a handbook of things like you just can't
do.
>> I'm not a supporter of targeting
anyone's revenue. I think it can damage
the entire landscape.
>> Or abusing copyright.
>> There's also the issue regarding rapid
copyright abuse on the platform that
YouTube has done nothing about.
>> been ban evading and breaking TOS
through multiple false copyright
strikes.
>> YouTubers who abuse built-in support
systems to silence creators who are
critical of them are the worst of the
worst. And defending free speech.
>> The worst of the worst, you guys, guys.
The worst
YouTubers who use the DMCA system to
silence their critics are the worst of
the worst, guys. Does he keep that
energy? of holiday? Apparently, Jeff
takes a holiday from free speech. He
locked replies and attempted to silence
criticism. I have no [__] problem
with anybody being a leftist, as long as
you don't try to infringe upon my free
speech. So, because of that
outspokenness and his proximity to other
large creators, Nick was always a
somewhat prominent voice helping enforce
the core standards for his corner of the
internet. However, recently, Nicholas
has pivoted to covering almost
exclusively Ethan Klein and his enemies,
or to put it more specifically, sucking
Ethan Klein's balls for 25 hours a week.
>> What I think Ethan should do is he
should use the GoFundMe money from the
lawsuits to buy all of these things. I
think he should take all that money and
then buy Anisa's house.
>> If everybody can see that what Ethan is
doing is so [__] up, then why are you
guys getting so much hate?
>> Ladies and gentlemen, Ethan Klein has
confirmed that his motion to subpoena
Reddit and Discord was granted. Ooh. His
relentless positive coverage eventually
got him noticed by the Kleins
themselves.
>> I love Nicholas DeOrio. I'll say it.
I've been watching your content. I think
you're very I think you're very funny
guy.
>> and
and I I feel like your coverage has been
really good on topics that I end up
watching. Like you really you're good
with research. He's seen consistent
growth in subscribers, likely from H3
viewers, ever since he shifted his
focus. And as a result, Nick has been
cemented as Ethan Klein's number one
lieutenant. His top guy.
>> He is one of the largest pro-Ethan
anti-Hasan mouthpieces on YouTube. And
while I'm never [music] one to begrudge
somebody making some money, today what
we are interested in is what he's had to
sacrifice to get it. Nick has become
somewhat representative of what it means
to be afflicted with the Hasan bad
virus. Unlike some of the other subjects
of this video, Nick is in fact not some
kind of rapist or pedophile, at least
not that I'm aware of. But he is every
bit as dishonest as the rest of these
guys. And in a lot of ways, he's worse.
You see, Nick has spent the last several
years carefully fine-tuning So, okay.
So, right right right. So, some DeOrio
speds are freaking out over this line.
>> representative of This is legit this is
being used to dismiss the entire video,
by the way.
>> interested in is what he's had to
sacrifice to get it. Nick has become
somewhat representative of what it means
to be afflicted with the Hasan bad
virus. Unlike some of the other subjects
of this video, Nick is in fact not some
kind of rapist or [music] pedophile, at
least not that I'm aware of. But he is
every bit as dishonest as the rest of
these guys. And in a lot of ways, he's
worse. So, every bit as dishonest and in
a lot of ways worse. Not in every way.
He's not saying more dishonest
necessarily. He's saying as dishonest
and in some ways worse. But, you know,
that's that's Keemstar's interpretation.
That's not really substantive to the
allegations in the video. That's a
subjective assessment of who he sees
worse and better. It's not very
substantive to any of the arguments in
the video, is it? You see, Nick has
spent the last several years carefully
fine-tuning a perfect system [music] for
lying. A system where he can be as
dishonest as he needs to be, use it to
his benefit, and avoid almost any
consequences. It's a process that if
followed to a T, can lead to massive
profit at the cost of your dignity. An
exchange that Nick happens to be
perfectly happy with. Now,
unfortunately, unfortunately for Nick,
he has slipped up in a few places.
Unfortunately, Nick has made some unwise
decisions in the course of this. Uh
we'll be we'll be talking about a few of
those. We'll be talking about a few of
those.
>> So, let's walk through, step by step,
exactly how Nicholas Deorio deceives his
audience, protects his income, and lies
directly to your face.
>> I can't wait to disagree with Ethan
Klein again, because I know that he's
principled and he actually gives a [__]
about what he's saying. This is the
Nicky D system.
A story breaks.
>> [music]
>> It's a story that on its face doesn't
look very good for Ethan Klein. Ethan is
accused of falsely copyright striking
numerous clips on the H3 Snark
subreddit. At best, Ethan is striking
clips that he doesn't have great reason
to, and at worst, he's trying to flood
the subreddit with copyright notices to
try to trigger an automatic ban.
Nicholas Deorio has been covering all
things Ethan Klein and even Snark for
months. So, he definitely sees things
like this when they pop up. And we do
know that he is specifically aware of
this story.
>> he has copyright struck a literal
subreddit. I wouldn't put it past him at
all. What the [__] dude? But, Nick also
knows that Oh, wow. No need to
investigate that. Wow, someone's saying
that Ethan Klein was copyright striking
Snark. No need to investigate that. No
need to investigate those claims. Sure,
people who abuse DMCA are the worst of
the worst. But, why would you ever need
to investigate a claim like this when
you're covering Ethan? Who cares, man?
Who cares? But, this story is a problem,
because if he covers it honestly, it
might involve criticizing Ethan. And if
he criticizes Ethan, he could be risking
>> might be able to write that off though,
right? You know, he just saw a Reddit
comment, you know? Or Nick saw he just
saw a Reddit comment, it said it, no
substantiation. It can be it can be
written off as quick as it's as it's
seen. So we
Yeah, who can really blame him? Who can
really blame him? his new association
with H3. So Nick considers his options
and decides that [music] the best course
of action is step one,
neglect. Simply neglect to cover stories
that are unfavorable to Ethan Klein. If
you don't talk about it, you don't have
to take a position on it. And if you
don't take a position on it, nobody can
hold you accountable for having the
wrong one. Sure, people might expect you
to have strong opinions about somebody
abusing DMCA.
>> YouTubers who abuse built-in support
systems with multiple false [music]
copyright strikes. The issue regarding
rapid copyright abuse on the platform.
But that's their problem. Nobody
controls their content. You don't have
to cover anything.
>> are like, "Well, Nick, if you go by your
principles, you'd defend these people."
My principles don't say I ever have to
cover anything on YouTube. They just say
that's my principle. I can just go,
"Yeah, dude, I think that this lawsuit
is kind of dumb." and then cover
something else that day if that's how I
really feel. I don't have to defend you.
I'm not going to. See, you can keep
talking about Hasan and Snark and H3.
You just skip the parts that make Ethan
look bad. And that is Nick's preferred
way of navigating anything that paints
Ethan in a negative light. It's clean.
All right, sure. It's safe. Remember
when Ethan used Mikaela Rain's warm body
as a prop for his anti-snark campaign?
Nick, to this day, has never fully
covered that story.
So and you'll remember there was a big
fuss about this. Alex Keckmaut obviously
huge Nicholas Deorio dick rider for for
many years. Uh people have been saying,
people saying, "Huge Nicholas Deorio
dick rider is one of the top RFC fans."
Um set a standard that at the day all
this was going down, he had a Twitter
space. And he set a standard. He said,
"I expect Nick to cover this properly
tonight, to actually call out Ethan like
he did with the Etika stuff. Otherwise,
I'm done. I'm done. That's it. This is
too far for me. The Ethan stream has
gone too far. Lo and behold, what
[__] happened? Nick neglects to cover
it. Curious. Most curious. Despite
indicating in passing that he disagreed
with what Ethan did.
>> Save a fox, killed herself from uh on a
snark sub. It is crazy and yet Yeah, the
same guy that Nick referred to as as the
the commentary reaper. Nick always used
to call this guy. He said, "If you get
in beef with Alex Gekko, it's only a
matter of time until you're outed and
you have your local downfall." That's
what he always used to say. That's what
they always used to say about this guy.
I just I completely disagree with this.
Credit does nothing. And that was it. He
avoided everything anything about Ethan
directly, which is also what he did with
the DMCA story for months. But avoidance
kind of has a shelf life. You can't just
do it forever. Eventually, something
will come up on stream that you can't
just look away from. And when that
happens, Nick proceeds to step two.
Ignorance.
Nick is streaming. He's covering Ethan
or iDubbbz and probably making some kind
of a penis joke.
>> said discipline, for some reason I
thought he was going to like It sounds
like they're talking about like their
[__] [__] which is ironically the
size of iDubbbz's penis.
>> This guy's trying to suck his own dick.
>> Get on your knees and suck dick. Cradled
their balls.
>> Cluck my own [__] Suck my [__]
>> Penis. Penis. Penis. Penis. Penis.
Jesus.
Anyway, something pops up on screen.
Something Nick has been trying to avoid,
but he's already been doing that for a
quite a while. He can't make it obvious
that he's been hiding from a story, but
thankfully, he still doesn't really need
to say anything bad about Ethan. Not
yet. He can simply choose to remain
ignorant about the topic. Easy. You
haven't looked into it. You don't know
enough yet. You're still waiting on more
information.
Let's go to July of last year. Nick is
reacting to this video by Paige Christie
about Ethan's war on h3 snark.
Oh, right. Note that this is 7 months
after the DMCA story originally became
public.
Right. So, that's since July of last
year, we're saying. But, when's this
video from? But, this video is from
January of 2025. That's That's curious,
isn't it, guys? Now, why would Nick,
apropos of nothing, just remember, "Oh,
yeah, I've got a video that maybe I
should respond to from 6 months ago."
That's it That seems a bit strange,
doesn't it, guys? That seems a little
bit strange.
And you may be mistaken, you know, you
may be easily mistaken as a Nicholas De
Orio fan. You may believe that Nick De
Orio just decided to go and cover this
critical video of him that was released
6 months ago cuz yeah, he just wants to
He wants to take accountability. He
wants to make sure that he's responding
to all criticism, right? That's what
That's what you may think if you're an
uncritical De Orio fan. Now, does that
seem particularly likely, guys? I don't
I don't personally think, even alone,
that sounds particularly likely that he
just randomly remembered this video.
Now, Nicholas De Orio streamed about it
on the 7th of July, okay? Streamed it on
the 7th of July 2025. Here, you'll see
me on the 7th of July 2025 earlier in
the day saying to Aiden, "By the way,
give it at least 5 days before you run
to De Orio to confront him with those
points from earlier."
Aiden replies, "Okay, do you have
something planned?" Then, De Orio's
segment gets posted a few days later.
Did you rat out that Paige Christie
stuff? So, just to make it clear, that's
what's being referred to here. Why am I
seeing Big Nick covering it in his
latest video? How much did you share?
Hold up, I'm streaming. I don't think I
shared anything, but if I did, it was
probably an in passing comment when he
asked me what the problem with his
coverage was. Also, did not know that
was private. So, Aiden seems to deny it
there. Yet, later in the conversation,
he says, "Well, with the Paige stuff, I
maybe made an in passing comment, which
was a mistake. I'll be more careful. And
I spoke to Aiden just earlier today,
guys. I spoke to Aiden just earlier
today. And Aiden told me he is almost
certain he spoke to Nick about the
Paigecristie stuff at this time. So, I
can't prove that Nicholas Deorio only
heard of simply heard about it from
Aiden. This is a criticism that I may be
making and desperately attempted to get
in front of it because he knew there was
fire coming his way and there was a
loose end he wanted to try and tie up. I
can't prove that, guys, but it certainly
seems like the most likely explanation.
It's uh It certainly seems like the most
likely explanation here. Um let me see
if I can just grab So, Aiden said Aiden
said he's totally fine for me to
reaffirm that this happened, you know,
I'm not leaking this without any
permission or anything, you know? So,
this is from today.
Yeah, I'm rereading the convo of I was
certain I brought this up to Nick,
especially since I now remember you
laying out the specific argument out in
the call with Jay Stoke, which would
have made me confident in arguing it to
him direct since I didn't think it was
private. I'd say that publicly. So, like
I say, guys, I can't prove that the only
reason Nicholas Deorio covered this
Paigecristie video 6-7 months after it
was released because of me putting
pressure on him via Aiden. I can't prove
that, but it certainly does seem like
the most reasonable explanation. Now,
what was Nick running from in this
video, guys? What was Nick running from
in this video? And how did he try and
respond to it cuz you'd think, right?
You'd think Nick gets tipped off that
there's going to be a big criticism
coming his way about the way he's
handled this DMCA issue. You'd think get
up on stream and just say it was wrong.
Just say Ethan was wrong, right? You'd
You'd think that You could easily You
you defuse it so quick. People are about
to come after you for something and
you've got the opportunity to just take
the wind out of his That's what you
think he would do. That's what you think
he would do, right? You would You would
hope. Snark, note that this is 7 months
after the DMCA story originally became
public. Here Nick summarizes his
coverage of the situation to this point.
>> rumor was he was striking people who
were doing market replacement type
content where it's like intentionally
pushing views away from original
content. So that was all that I said was
if that's the case, that's probably like
fine. And again, I was waiting for a
formal video to break this down
or I was waiting for Ethan to announce a
lawsuit. We mentioned this like [__]
multiple times.
I was waiting to see what would actually
get taken down. [music] Okay, but the
problem here is that this was a
breakdown video. The breakdown video is
on screen right now. The documentation
from Ethan's own attorneys is publicly
available in that video along with some
examples of what was getting struck. But
does Nick take the few minutes he would
need to learn about that information?
No. In fact, he never even reacted to
this video. He only pulled up this small
snippet while covering a completely
different topic. And Nick made sure the
whole time to performatively remind his
viewers how little he wanted to watch
Paige's video. I hope they all find
employment soon. So yeah, let's just go
over let's just go over to Paige
Christie's video real quick. So what
what is Nick dodging here? Let's take a
look. What happens here, guys?
>> People have noticed that AB, one of the
members of the H3 H3 podcast, was in
Nicholas De Orio's DMs. Other members of
the H3 snark Reddit had also noticed
that my name was there, too. And that
started the whole we don't like Paige,
she supports yada yada yada.
Now I have had a parasocial love-hate
relationship with Nicholas De Orio for
quite some time. I respect him as a
content creator. I think he's [__]
fantastic at what he does, even if I
don't agree with him. However, as a
person I find him insufferable, as he
does with me, he doesn't like me either.
However, I would say that there was a
small amount of more so amount of mutual
respect. I stay in my corner, you stay
in yours, and we're good. However, when
I found out the update of the H3H3 snark
Reddit, as well as the lawsuits and
legal documents and all of that kind of
stuff, I reached out to Nicholas DeOrio
to let him know about it. As you can see
on the screen, this is exactly what I
said to Nicholas DeOrio. So, let's read
this. Hey DeOrio, just leaving you a
tip. Ethan Klein has been abusing the
copyright system despite his history of
fighting for fair use. And so, this is
the post that we just read that lays out
the exact durations of the clips and
what was struck and when. If he's
striking down posts that are here, watch
this mirror, and don't give Ethan views,
then that's based on best practices,
says Nick. Paige says, No, he's not. I'd
say that would be fair, also, but that's
not what he's doing. We're talking clips
that are 20 seconds or 1 minute, not
exactly intended to rip off a 3-hour
plus podcast. Clear as day, Paige
Christie tells him this in January of
2025.
That's before the content you comes out.
That's before CPS is called. That's
before lawsuits are issued. That's
before [__] all of it. And he sits
there, he knows about it, and he sweeps
the whole [__] time regardless for
someone he knows is a DMCA abuser. He
has been handed the information on a
silver platter straight to his DMs,
engaged with it, had the Reddit post
right there. He knows. And if he doesn't
know, it's deliberate. It's deliberate
because he has deliberately avoided
clicking that link cuz he never wants to
even consider engaging with criticism of
it because he knows what position he's
going to take anyway. So, he wants to
try and feign ignorance at every point.
He wants to be as ignorant as possible
at every point. It's clear as day.
DeOrio swept for the DMCA abuse. Ethan
Klein filed false DMCA strikes and
Nicholas De Oreo knowingly swept for it.
Knowingly covered it up. Knowingly did
not cover it. Deliberately. Clear as
day. There's no way around it. And then
when it did and then watch his segment.
We'll watch his segment replying to this
and keep in mind the whole time that the
likely explanation from covering this is
that he's been prompted to. That he's
been prompted to by Aiden. Let's keep
watching Page Kristie video for a
moment. Now I did this because whilst
Nicholas De Oreo will suck the literal
skin off Ethan Klein's phallic object, I
do believe that Nicholas De Oreo is a
man of his word and he understands that
fair is fair and he is more than willing
to call out friends which I've seen
numerous times over his career on
YouTube for the good of what is right. I
literally saw this boy disown his very
good friend Jon Swan over lies that he
told that reflected bad on the
commentary community. Nicholas I have to
put a bullet in every single one of my
friends' heads.
Going to be doing a lot of I'm going to
be doing a lot of that this week I fear.
I'm going to be doing a lot of that this
week I fear. Nicholas De Oreo went out
of his way to make a stance and say this
is [__] up and I don't stand by it.
Now I did also think to myself that
maybe Nicholas De Oreo just simply
doesn't care about
>> Why don't why don't the box say what's
coming up next? infringements and false
copyright claims. Okay, let's kill this
video. Page Kristie, you escaped being a
segment a couple of months ago Page
Kristie. Did you make a snark defense
video that we never actually got around
to watch? This one.
>> Ethan Klein.
>> I got two seconds you can tell
>> So yeah, yeah, yeah. So watch how he
brings this up guys. Watch how he brings
this up. someone to ICE. People
reporting people to an authoritair group
so they could be taken away gives World
War camp vibes. For the record it is
illegal to falsely report someone to ICE
it's a crime. I can't imagine disliking
a stranger on the internet so much that
you report them to the Gestapo. Using
fascism as a weapon against YouTubers, I
guess calling ISIS the new swatting. Are
we We Well, we are right at [__]
dawn. I can't imagine this the tickets
are selling that well. Holy [__] dude.
That's funny. Um let me see what else
here. It's like when people used to
frame people they didn't like as
witches. Yeah, it's exactly like that.
>> [laughter]
>> I hope they all find employment soon.
Paige Christie.
>> [sighs]
>> Paige Christie, you escaped being a
segment a couple of months ago, Paige
Christie. Escaped being a segment.
What's in her video? Undeniable proof
that Nicholas DeOrio was informed that
Ethan Klein was committing DMCA abuse
and that he swept anyway. You narrowly
escaped it, Paige. You narrowly escaped
it. Oh, Paige, you you almost got
totally owned by me by me, Nick. Now,
keep in mind, guys. Here's what you'll
notice as well. You remember how
Noxtaku, when confronted with
potentially career-ending allegations,
how did he respond? He buried his
response, his deflection, deep into a
50-minute Hasan [__] video, right? We
all We all remember that. We all
remember how Hasan out Noxtaku did that.
Well, Nicholas DeOrio here has buried
his response to Paige Christie 45
minutes into an Adam McIntyre [__]
video, guys. His His response to the
undeniable, clear as day proof that he
swept for DMCA abuse is buried 45
minutes into his [__] Adam McIntyre
video, guys. I feel like I I feel like I
remember what that was about. Did you
have something to do with your
with your snark defense video? Did you
make a snark defense video that we never
actually got around to watch? Paige
Christie, yeah, those unemployed snark
people are the worst. Did you ever make
a video? This one.
>> It's an incline.
>> I got 2 seconds. You can tell I got 2
seconds into it. Uh let's see. What are
we saying here?
Let me see.
What?
Let's take a look. Nicholas.
Let me see. Actually, let's just go to
Snark.
Oh, 50 mentions.
Interesting. Friendly fire, Nicholas
Deorio. What was this segment about?
>> No. So, so, guys, he knows in advance
there is a segment about him in this
video, right? Just stumbled upon upon a
comment. Stumbled upon a comment
randomly. Doesn't, you know, this is a
video from 6 months ago that you never
watched. Never watched the escape being
a segment. You never watched it. But he
knows there's a segment about him. And
he goes there and immediately starts
looking for the segment about him.
Again, you can't prove anything. Leash
my hand, I guess. Nicholas Deorio. Now,
whilst in a live stream, Nicholas
Deorio, as he stupidly does quite
frequently, ended up showing
>> [laughter]
>> Wait, she's right. I did. I actually
did. No. No, I leaked all my DMs, bro.
You could see my messages with Mauler.
showing his inbox on Twitter. To which
people had noticed that AB, one of the
members of the H3H3 podcast, was in
Nicholas Deorio's DM. What was my DM?
Wait, hold on. What was it? What did I
say to AB? I can tell you what it is. No
problem. Let me see. What was no
problem? I actually wonder what the
context of this DM was cuz I only have
like a few DMs with AB. So, it'll take
like 2 seconds to find. Was this when I
warned him about This might be when I
warned him about bad empanada
before all the drama started. Cuz
Um oh, it was to send a I sent along the
Rosanna AB thumbnail thing. That's what
that was. That was on January 6th.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude, the most iconic January 6th
reveal. His inbox on Twitter. Who is in
here? Wait, oh my god. Dude, this is
[__]
>> [laughter]
>> insane.
Wait, dude, these DMs are ridiculous.
Look at all the names, bro. This is like
actually [__] insane. Dude, so
there's just one guy there's a fake
Augie, Mr. Beast, Lieutenant Cobra, Alex
Yggy Mo, Colossus is crazy, Paige
Christie, Mauler, the Boston Tea Party
group chat from the iconic leaks, and
then the house group chat
>> Some of this is funny in ways you guys
don't even appreciate, I think.
Some of this is funny in ways you won't
appreciate, I think.
Dude, Tipster. Dude, it's Tipster, fake
Augie, Mr. Beast, Lieutenant Cobra, AND
COLOSSUS IS CRAZY.
>> [laughter]
>> DUDE, I'M actually like Tipster
>> love that. I love fake posting. Fake
posting t-shirt. Fake posting hat.
And is there Mutahar in there? I love
fake posting. I [__] love fake fake
posting.
To which people had noticed that AB, one
of the members of the H3H3 pod It's not
really fair to critique this in current
day. This was made a long time ago.
>> was in Nicholas DeOrio's DMs. Other
members of the H3 Snark Reddit had also
noticed that my name was there, too. And
that started the whole we don't like
Paige. She supports
>> [laughter]
>> So, is that why you sent me to the corn,
Paige Christie? Because the Snark
subreddit started turning on you for
associating with
By the way, you you act like we're like
friendly or whatever. You spelled my
name wrong, you [__] [__] It's
literally in my [__] channel. My name
is my channel. It's extremely easy to
spell it right.
>> Now, I've had a parasocial love-hate
relationship with Nicholas DeOrio for
quite some time.
>> think I've ever loved you. I respect him
as a content creator. That's not what
that means, you [__] [__] That's
not what that means. She said she's had
a parasocial,
as in one-sided, [__] love-hate
relationship with you. As in, she has
love and hate feelings towards you. You
[__] [__] He's so dumb, bro. I
think he's [__] fantastic. Thank you.
at what he does, even if I don't agree
with him. However, as a person, I find
him insufferable. As he does with me, he
doesn't This is fair. This is a fair
argument.
>> Like me, either. However, I would say
that there was a small amount of morsel
amount of mutual respect. I stay in my
corner, you stay in yours, and we're
good. However, when I found out the
update of Your corner is like way off to
the side, though. You're not completely
out of the way, you know? Some would say
it's like, you know, just like a little
area off to the the H3 snark Reddit, as
well as the lawsuits and legal documents
and all of that kind of stuff, I reached
out to Nicholas De Orio to let him know
about it. As you can see on the screen,
this is exactly what I said to Nick. Oh,
she leaked my DMs. I think I wrote back
to her knowing that she was going to
leak my DMs. That was the intention. Um,
guys, this was all
Guys, these DMs, where I totally exposed
myself unknowingly sweeping for damn
shame. You see, this is all 50 chats,
actually. You don't understand. Orio,
just leaving you a chat. How do you Why
do you keep Look at this. Look at this.
I actually need to [__] point this
out to you.
How do you spell my name wrong? It's
Look. Look.
Look. Everyone just keeps spelling his
name like this. He spells it like this.
Hey De Orio. How? How? How do you click
on someone's DMs and spell their name
wrong? How do you do that? How do you
How do you [__] This is insane.
Nicholas De Orio. Now, I did this
because what What did I say in this? Why
don't you speak Italian? Why Cuz I
stopped responding to her, cuz I
realized that this wasn't like a
friendly conversation. This is content.
>> However, as a person, I find him
insufferable mutual respect. I stay in
my
>> Guys, I stopped responding because it
wasn't like a friendly conversation. It
was content. Not because I was on the
record
having been sent uh, uh, clear evidence
that Ethan Klein was abusing the MCIA.
Okay. However, when I found out the
update of the H3 H3 snark Reddit, as
well as the lawsuits and legal documents
and all of that kind kind
I reached out to Nicholas De Orio to let
him know about it. As you can see on the
Okay. Um
let's see. It was "Hi, just leaving you
a tip here. Ethan Klein has been abusing
the copyright system despite his history
of fighting for fair use." Wow.
>> [laughter]
>> Now, it seems like he's been targeting
things that were supposed to be market
replacements, but So, Nick has been
provide in these DMs, Nick benefits from
not showing you this Reddit thread or
any of the surrounding evidence in this
segment. In these DMs, Nick has been
shown evidence of Ethan Klein's strikes.
That Reddit post lays it all out and I
believe has a legal letter attached and
everything. It's literally it's right
there. He has acknowledged it. He has
been sent it. I I almost think um
I might have even mentioned that on
stream, but it sounds like that's what
they were that like what he's mad about
now is what he was mad about then,
right? But I don't know if he's striking
down posts that are here watch this
mirror and don't give Ethan the views.
That's based and best practices is what
I said. This is literally Do you know
the lawsuit stuff that happened
recently? This is back in This is in
January.
>> then what happens next? Basically, she
says, "No, he's not."
>> Larry. I don't know how long these DM
These DMs might have even like crawled
back into um December, but the rumor was
he was striking people who were doing
market replacement type content where
it's like intentionally pushing views
away from original content. So, that was
all that I'd said was if that's the
case, that's probably like fine. "No,
he's not." I'd say that would be fair
also, but that's not what he's doing. I
have a question. So, what is Paige
Christie's current position on the
Denims, Frogan, and um
and Casey Tron lawsuits? So, isn't this
amazing, guys? Deorio, likely knowing
there is going to be criticism coming
his way for this, he's presented a
couple different options, but we'll just
lay out two. One, he could simply fold
and accept that Paige Christie didn't of
this. He could pull up the right here
third on stream. He could offer a clear
condemnation of Ethan Klein abusing the
DMCA system to attempt to get a forum
talking [__] about him shut down. That's
number one. That's option number one.
That would totally take the wind out of
the sails of any criticism. Everyone
would have to admit, "No, fair enough,
Nick. You've taken your opportunity to
be principled and you've stood on it."
But no. Nick decides that And this is
literally this is what buries him here.
This is what buries him here. You can't
prove that, you know, he's this [__]
aware without him getting on stream and
doing this stupid [__] But no.
Presented with an opportunity to correct
the record, to offer the principled
position, his final opportunity, he
decides instead to just [__] deflect.
Just [__] deflect and go, "What do
you think about the current lawsuits,
hm? Hm? Well, if you're okay with Ethan
striking complete reuploads, then you
have to be okay with the current
lawsuits, which are actually about
reactions and actually vary in uh how
transformative they were. And one of
them was in fact uh uh more
transformative than than uh my reaction
was. But no. It's it's [__] crazy,
man. It's totally crazy. It's so insane,
man. How is this not just dead to
rights? Seriously, I'm I'm inviting any
TheOriana fan, any [__] idiot content
creator. I don't think Smeggle was
defending TheOriana at this point. But
anyone who wants to come on and defend
this, seriously. Dickers avoiding this
right now as well. Anyone defend this,
seriously, I'd love to talk to you. This
is clear as [__] day. TheOriana
betraying one of the most core
principles. Augie, if Augie doesn't
cover this, the big sweep's on, by the
way, for the third time. Uh fourth time
even. Uh it's [__] crazy. Anyone
defend this, seriously, this is one of
the most core principles. All these guys
defended, Augie, Bob Backs, Nick, all
these guys have been pounding for
[__] years about DMCA abuse,
archiving being okay, full re-uploads
being okay. [__] everything, man.
They go [__] crazy with it. Now, I'm
willing to accept a more common sense
fair use position as you've grown older,
but this is absolutely outside the
bounds. This is absolutely outside the
bounds. There's no [__] excuse for
it, and this fat lying [__] knew. He
knew, and he covered it up because he
was certain this was against his
principles. He knew there was no excuse
for this one. There's no amount of "Oh,
they deserve it. They deserve it." you
can do about shutting down a forum when
it was months before the CPS school,
it's months before any of the other
lawsuits, months before the [__]
schools. Totally totally separate. You
literally you cannot make any argument.
He is dead to [__] rights, backed
into the corner like a [__] animal,
dude. And he has nowhere to go on this.
Nowhere to go on this, and he will never
address it because of that. Unless
someone literally makes him, he will
never address this inconsistency. And if
he attempts to, it'll be more
whataboutism deflecting [__] And
you [__] know it. And I will [__]
argue with anyone about it, argue any of
these [__] [__] any of these
[__] [__] cock-sucking small
commentary channels with [__] 70
subscribers who get 20 concurrents and
just repeat what Nick says, any [__]
Spicy Crisp or just Pegasisters, anyone.
Anyone who disagrees with this can come
on, call in, tell me exactly how either
these DMCAs are defensible or how Nick
didn't know and didn't completely betray
every [__] principle that his gaggle
of [__] [__] friends claimed was
important. And let me remind you guys,
there is a tweet from Nicholas DeOrio
talking about how I don't know if it's
about uh it's about deplatforming
campaigns, which this is, by the way.
Ethan's goal here was use DMCAs to
deplatform the Snouts over it. He has a
tweet about deplatforming campaigns
where he says, "All these YouTubers
feeling confident during the platforming
campaigns means we're not doing our job
well enough." Basically saying we should
be hounding these people more. Where was
that when this was happening? Where was
that when this was happening, Nick? Is
it only fun when you're going off to
some stupid [__] [__] who can't
fight back? Is that the only time it's
fun for you, Nick? When it's against
children or women? When it's against
children or women who can't fight back?
It's not that you go after children, but
you know, you get the point I'm making,
people weaker than you. Is that the only
time it's fun for you, Nick? Cuz that's
the only time you can you can get off on
it. Is it when maybe when it's a maybe
when it's a wealthy Jew who bothers your
bread? Maybe then it's a little bit more
difficult. There is no way out of this.
There is no excuse for this. They have
him nothing. And it's even more
hilarious that it's Paige Christie who
got him on this. So, you know, I don't
mean to deride her at all, but there is
like some left-leaning, you know, black
woman, overweight black woman. By all
accounts to all these commentary guys
who, you know,
absolutely feast on people being easy
targets for young, white, right-wing
audiences. Let's be totally honest here.
Let's just be real with ourselves about
what happens, whether it's some wretched
trans freak or some [__] woman who's
telling, you know, gamers that they're
they're worthless or or saying the yeah
saying the N-word's bad or some [__] or
some weak man, you know, whatever it is.
An easy target for the crowds they
appeal to. And Paige [__] raped him.
Has him dead to rights in DMs
acknowledging something that totally
betrays all of his principles. And he
literally, when he goes to cover it, he
can't even muster a real defense. It's
just, "Well, what's your opinion on the
current lawsuits?" And when it doesn't
contradict at all. It's totally easy,
totally acceptable for her to have a
position that you can't strike these
random [__] clips, um but you can
strike for reuploads, or you can strike
for reuploads, but you shouldn't sue
Denims Dragon and Casey Tron. Those are
all You can hold all those positions at
once and it not be contradictory because
you can think that no commentary is too
little commentary. So a full re-upload
is is a market replacement with no
commentary. A small clip with a title is
simply a contained piece that doesn't
create a market replacement and provide
substantive critical commentary for the
amount of content used. And then you can
also think that a full-scale react when
you're mentioned in the video, even if
it's not fully substantive, is also
allowed. You can hold all these
positions at once and it not be
contradictory. But Nick desperately
tries to use this [__] hypocrisy
point when it's meaningless. There's
nothing to it and nobody could defend
this again. So they've got nothing.
Totally raped. You're a [__] [__]
DeOro defender still. You're totally
raped on this. DeOro is totally raped on
this and it's only going to get worse.
It's only going to get worse. I got 2
seconds into it. It's pretty
unsurprising to me that Paige escaped
becoming a segment on Nick's channel.
You see in situations like this, Nick
isn't actually waiting on more
information. He's waiting for the story
to go away. Sometimes he'll be scrolling
around on stream and Nick might
accidentally stumble upon some of that
information that he's supposedly waiting
on.
>> Okay.
Do this or get sued. Your only option to
avoid litigation. You provide
[clears throat] our office with all
correspondence you had with the
moderators of H3 Snark. So he's got
he's seen the legal letter too. He's
seen the legal letter. He's seen the
extraneous demands being made by Ethan
as legal team for these forum users. Off
of a DMCA.
>> QueenMan streams are so peak it's just 5
minutes of no commentary from QueenMan
and then the most insanely correct truth
new queue have ever heard.
>> Thanks for $5 DoFo. Huge appreciate.
Thank you. I choose my words wisely.
So he's seen this legal warning. Is it
on Assume the DMCA was justified. Assume
it was a market replacement just for a
moment. Imagine that. Would this legal
letter be justified? Remember what it
asks. It asks for this user to hand over
a bunch of communication with just
random other internet users under threat
of litigation that would probably
destroy them from what I believe now.
Even if it was a legitimate DMCA, that
would be crazy. That would be totally
wrong. Guess this is happening now. This
is This is happening. The H3 Snark
lawsuit. Uh-oh, that letter looks kind
of bad for Ethan, doesn't it? How will
Nick respond? Keep in mind that federal
court filings are public. Anyone
performing a simple Google search on
you, little one background check will
discover this
information. You have until March 25th,
2025 at 5:00 p.m. to agree to these
terms. So, I don't know when this was
sent. Noah Samson made a community
>> He just streams past it. No curiosity,
no interest in learning more about it.
We just move [music] on. He's choosing
to remain ignorant about the story.
Going back to Michaela Rain's, this was
his playbook also.
>> I'm not going to cover this story cuz I
feel like there's a ton of
misinformation coming out about it.
Supposedly this was related to a snark.
Apparently the husband's saying it has
other
I don't know. A lot of people are making
huge sweeping assessments based off this
person's suicide. A lot of people, like
who, Nick? And that's bad, right, Nick?
>> I'm not going to sit here and speculate
on it. Um
yeah, I don't know.
>> [laughter]
>> Realistically, I'm not going to delve
super deep into an unrelated story to
try to to do investigate on how she
died. Uh so, that's my stance on that
position.
But with Azaka, but with Azaka, it was
the worst thing Ethan had ever done.
What What [__] Ethan ever done when it
was Azaka?
When it was easy to stand on, when
everyone cared, when it was epic
Nintendo man, when everybody Nintendo
man, everyone loved. It's part of
Ethan's entire justification for trying
to eliminate snark communities from the
internet. This is something Nick has
been agreeing with and pushing for
months. But because Ethan is the one
making the claims about Michaela's
death, he all of a sudden doesn't have
enough information. We just don't know.
I'm not going to speculate. It's not
even relevant. This stuff works pretty
well on a lot of people. Between these
first two steps, Nick can generally do
extremely one-sided coverage and cater
to a very specific audience without much
worry about anybody caring or maybe even
noticing, except when they do.
Eventually, people do start noticing and
when they do, Nick moves to step three,
contingency.
People are starting to notice.
Something's off. They're watching Nick's
coverage and they're thinking, "Huh,
this guy never criticizes Ethan. It's
almost like he's
sweeping." Which is a suggestion He made
a whole dedicated to Etika tribute and
his Ethan video in 2020. that Nick
doesn't take too kindly to.
>> The big sweep might be on.
>> So, this guy stuck a dagger right into
my neck the minute we stopped talking
about
>> It's hilarious, man, cuz it's like the
whole criticism is Ethan uses people's
dead bodies, right? That's the whole
criticism. And then, by not applying
that principle consistently, he shows
that he was using Etika's dead body. He
was actually parading Etika's dead body
around just as much as Ethan was. Cuz he
doesn't actually give a [__] that Ethan
was doing it. It was just a criticism he
could levy at Ethan. So, he just
demonstrates never mattered to him in
the first place. It was just an excuse
to use someone's [__] corpse to
impugn his enemies. Thank you for the
$9.99, Max. I really appreciate it.
Thank you. I'm going to implicate
>> is black magic. Anyways, I don't have
any extra money for the Patreon, but
hopefully you send this to Keela.
>> Yeah, no worries. No worries. Well,
well, we'll send that right to Keela,
trust me. Trust me. I will actually I've
just said in spicy. There is now a Keela
Tonics Patreon, guys. So, if you do
actually want to support Keela directly,
you can go and do that. Um it's 18 plus.
Yeah. There's a Patreon. There's a
Patreon, guys. that you're sweeping and
uh yeah, so I'm going to like rape you
in the ass on this one. You see, Nick
works pretty hard at trying to present
himself as the guy who always has the
correct take. He can only have people
>> Classic tweet. I'm on the right side of
nearly every drama. You know what this
is about, too. This is about [__] him
getting Carl Jobst wrong.
Him backtracking on defending Carl
Jobst. People were giving him [__] and
he's like, "No, I'm always right,
actually." Calling his credibility or
honesty into question. Not just because
he needs to protect his brand, but also
because he's extremely sensitive. So, he
does what any good liar does when they
start feeling pressure. He starts making
sure that he has a way out, a
contingency plan.
The trick is knowing when to do it. You
don't just criticize Ethan at random.
You wait for a moment where it's easy
and safe to appear critical. Something
minor, a slight disagreement or a half
criticism. Anything you can have on
record to point to so you can say that
you're impartial. To this point, Nick
has neglected to cover the DMCA story,
as well as the lawsuit against Stage 3
Snark, and he's also chosen to remain
ignorant about the details.
>> I haven't covered two things with Ethan
Klein. Uh there's the two things I
haven't really covered.
One being the lawsuit against the Snark
subreddits. But he also knows that the
story's not just going to go away. So,
at some point along the way, he starts
hedging.
>> Twitch streamers have been DMCA'ing
streamable links in Reddit posts for
like a decade. Dude. It was extremely
common for them to be striking clips.
And And look at how it changed. Look at
how the principle shift. DMCA abusers
were the worst of the worst. Now all of
a sudden, DMCA abuse is fine because uh
Alinity did it like 6 years ago. Guys,
Alinity did it like 6 years ago. Can you
believe it? No, it's not cool. Uh we
didn't think it was cool when Dark Viper
struck the clip of him uh getting mad at
Among Us. Um
>> [laughter]
>> When you're just doing 30-second clips,
40-second clips. And if that was what
Ethan was striking down, if they weren't
supposed to be market substitutes for
segments like, "Don't give the stream
the view, watch it here." Yeah, I mean,
that's kind of shitty. That's kind of
cringey. Kind of shitty, kind of kind of
shitty, kind of cringey if that's what
he was doing. Bear in mind, this is
months after he's been made aware of all
the information. He's the He's got the
information. This is just hedging. This
is just pure hedging. Statement is an
escape hatch. It's a hypothetical
criticism where he doesn't actually
commit to anything. If that's what Ethan
was doing, it would be kind of cringey.
Like he's not actually giving his
opinion on the topic, but the statement
is on the record now. If anyone accuses
Nick of sweeping for Ethan, he now has
this clip he can point to and say, "See,
I did disagree with Ethan all along." He
did the same thing when Ethan went after
sponsors, something Nick has loudly
opposed for years.
>> I'm not a supporter of targeting
anyone's revenue. I think it can damage
the entire landscape. But listen to
Nick's attitude on this behavior now.
>> I'm not in favor of attacking sponsors.
I haven't used my audience specifically
to go push this further like that. So, I
don't like that stuff. Uh realistically,
there's not much way to hold Twitch to
account. The weird double standard that
Hassan gets for all of his friends. This
is a corrupt platform. Uh and I think it
does need to be destroyed. That's my
personal opinion. I I don't agree with
Dan Saltman's methods to target sponsors
the way that he has. I agree a bit more
with the way that Ethan did it cuz he
was targeting TwitchCon, going over like
the panel that they approved. All right.
Remember how Ethan spoke about how Nick
spoke about Ethan targeting sponsors
back in the day? Remember, guys? Do you
remember? Back when Ethan made a big hit
piece going on about G Fuel this, G Fuel
that. This is on your [__] hat,
Keemstar. You're pushing rape
allegations with your [__] hat that
says G Fuel. Nick's like, "No, you can't
You can't target Keemstar's sponsors
like that. You can't target Keemstar's
sponsors like that. Put your house where
you can free house target your
sponsors." But when Ethan explicitly
years later targets sponsors saying he's
targeting sponsors for the purpose of
targeting sponsors to deplatform, to
hurt creator's income, all of a sudden
Nick's totally okay with it. That's
actually preferable to Dan's tactics
because all Dan always has to be framed
as the real evil in Ethan's life. It's
always just Dan's malign influence, not
Ethan doing anything himself. Or or his
lawyer acting His lawyer acting on his
own without instruction, putting stuff
in the lawsuit. Tate was always going to
have an adpocalypse.
This was happening either way. It's this
weird half condemnation where he
presents like he still has his older
more principled position.
>> I'm not in favor of attacking sponsors.
But literally everything else he says
goes against it.
>> a corrupt platform and I think it does
need to be destroyed.
>> This was happening either way. You're
not against targeting sponsors, Nick.
You're supporting it. You're just
playing both sides so you can defend
yourself no matter what. Nick actually
does this all the time.
>> Turing? He gives these mealy-mouthed
tepid half-baked criticisms where he's
not really [__] saying anything
meaningful, but then he'll go and point
to them later as evidence that he's
unbiased. Junktown Gaming, a small
commentary channel, helped identify this
pattern in a recent video pointing out
the massive holes in Nick's coverage.
Specifically, the fact that he had never
directly addressed Ethan exploiting
Michaela's death.
>> But despite boldly disagreeing with
Ethan on this over 6 months later, Nick
still's never addressed Ethan
weaponizing this woman's death to
bolster his campaign to remove his
detractor base from the internet. And
Nick's response
>> W U Junktown Gaming shout out. W
Junktown Gaming shout out huge. is
predictably was to claim that he had in
fact already criticized Ethan for this,
but he can't possibly be referring to
this.
>> I'm not going to cover this story cuz I
feel like there's a ton of
misinformation coming out about it.
>> Or this.
>> Yeah, I just I completely disagree with
this. So this supposed criticism must be
this. If we're going to make a critique
towards Ethan, the one that sticks in
the back of my mind, I think we covered
it briefly.
>> you hear those guys? Those are the two
previous addressings of uh
Save a Fox video. predictably was to
claim that he had in fact already
criticized Ethan for this, but he can't
possibly be referring to this.
>> I'm not going to cover this story cuz I
feel like there's a ton of
misinformation coming out about it. Or
this.
>> Yeah, I just I completely disagree with
this. So this supposed criticism must be
this. If we're going to make a critique
towards Ethan, the one that sticks in
the back of my mind, I think we covered
it No, [snorts] you didn't.
>> was there was a clip that came out was
it someone killed themselves on on
Reddit or something? Okay, already. Why
does it seem like he's just pretending
to not remember the details of the
story?
>> And they were blaming like a snark
subreddit that did it. No, not that.
>> guys, it's been plenty of time since he
was informed of those DMCA strikes,
right? And he has already he I believe
this is possible point where he's
hedging on stream acting as though, you
know, if those DMCA strikes were
frivolous, then then I that would be bad
and cringey. That would be cringey.
Yeah, when he sat here, he's saying,
"Oh, if you are going to make a
criticism of Ethan, if I have to come up
with one, I guess it'd be the save a fox
thing. I I can't think of anything else
though."
Ethan Ethan was the main person pushing
this talking point.
>> But then a couple hours later once
people did research, it realistically
didn't have anything to do with or it
didn't play a large role in what
happened to that person. Like the snark
community was extremely small, and then
it kind of got pushed into like this is
the danger of snark communities or
whatever. Okay, it got pushed. It got
pushed. You mean Ethan pushed it. Ethan
exploited a woman's death for his own
personal benefit, but Nick will never
say those words. He'll instead say
things like this.
>> like maybe waiting to kind of see how
things turn out before jumping on that
would benefit everybody. So Nick's key
criticism of Ethan was actually just him
giving general advice on how it would be
good for everybody to do more patient
research, and he avoids saying that
Ethan did anything wrong. And now he's
waving it around as proof that he's not
a complete hack, and he's just hoping
nobody goes back and checks.
But by this point, the criticism is
starting to mount. People aren't just
asking about Ethan, they're asking about
Nick, and that's a different kind of
problem because you can't exactly sweep
criticism of yourself under the rug. You
can either address it
or you can kill it.
Nick is starting to feel some heat.
People are asking questions such as why
the guy who built his career on things
like standing up against copyright abuse
is suddenly silent when Ethan Klein does
it. And every criticism of Ethan that
goes unanswered is a criticism of Nick
for not answering it. And he's aware of
that. So, when Nick runs cover for
Ethan, he's running cover for himself,
too. People are talking about him. And
Nick's go-to way of dealing with it is
to do absolutely anything he can to
simply disrupt
>> He used two words? Yeah, that's fine.
They do that in the Dennis system. What
do you mean? That's why he's ripping it
from. Why is it a Dennis system? They do
it in the Dennis system. It's like
nurture dependence and [__] like that,
right? think about Nick. And that's a
different kind of problem, because you
can't exactly sweep criticism of
yourself under the rug. You can either
address it
or you can kill it.
Nick is starting to feel some heat.
People are asking questions, such as why
the guy who built his career on things
like standing up against copyright abuse
is suddenly silent when Ethan Klein does
it. And every criticism of Ethan that
goes unanswered is a criticism of Nick
for not answering it. And he's aware of
that. So, when Nick runs cover for
Ethan, he's running cover for himself,
too. People are talking about him. And
Nick's go-to way of dealing with it is
to do absolutely anything he can to
simply disrupt the conversation, change
the subject, and make it about something
else. Reframe the attacks and make them
sound completely different. Anything he
can do to just kill the criticism. His
favorite tactic is, instead of actually
responding to things, he'll just try to
flip them around on the person making
the point.
>> none of these people speak up against I
don't even understand. None of these
people spoke up against Bad Empanada
when he struck my Twitter three times.
Are you serious? That's so crazy, guys.
It's almost like they're team sports.
The quick It's bad when Bad Empanada
strikes you, too. So, that's bad when
Bad Empanada docks his people. Dude, who
Who is he talking about? This Is it just
snarkers who's being random Reddit users
who don't stick up for him? What the
[__] is he talking about, man? What the
[__] is he saying? What is this
deflection, bro?
Criticism is about Ethan, Nick. Nobody
was asking if everyone else is being
consistent. What do you think about what
Ethan is doing? But Nick still uses this
move literally all the time.
>> And if that was what Ethan was striking
down, if they weren't supposed to be
market substitutes for segments like
don't give the stream the view, watch it
here. Yeah, I mean that's kind of
shitty, that's kind of cringey, but none
of these people operate in like the same
world, I guess. Bademupana That
literally, dude, that could be like
Destiny or food shops there. Do you know
what I mean? But none of these people
operate in like the same world. You
can't use the same it out of striking a
clip of a video that I own most of the
content of. That's fine because Nick Di
Oreo is bad, but Ethan Klein doing it is
horrible because Ethan Klein is trying
to censor people. By the way, I'm going
to need every single person who had the
take on stream that going after sponsors
is bad. I'm going to need their takes
audited. I want to know what they said 5
years ago about Keemstar. I want to know
what they said about Pokimane. I need
their take on all these situations to
know if they're [__] if they're just
sweeping. But the rumor was he was
striking people
Of course there's people who are against
targeting sponsors that are sweeping,
right, Nick? That This makes sense
somehow, guys. This makes sense somehow.
people who are doing market replacement
type content. So that was all that I'd
said was if that's the case, that's
probably like fine. No, he's not. I'd
say that would be fair also, but that's
not what he's doing. I have a question.
So what is Page Kristie's current
position on I I trust Salvo implicitly
too, actually. I I actually trust Salvo
implicitly. He has that trustworthy
vibe. He has good vibes. Casey Tron
lawsuits. Are we going to maintain this
position? I'm just curious. So the guy
you could leave your car keys with, I
feel like. I feel like mine's fairly
consistent. Are we going to maintain
this position that that would be fair
also? I'm just wondering. Clearly
instead of actually engaging with what's
being said and potentially saying
anything bad about Ethan, Nick would
rather just aimlessly hypocrisy hunt.
Anything to avoid being honest. Another
one of Nick's favorite maneuvers is to
just completely change what's being said
about him. Like when people point out
his totally biased coverage.
>> of these guys have been doing the Ethan
Klein Oh, Nick, you cover Ethan Klein
too much. I'm sorry. I have three
segments from the last stream. Would you
like me to post a 7-hour video instead?
I got to cut it up into pieces. Dude,
it's the great war being fought on the
battlefield of like I don't care about
Ethan Klein anymore and I'm lashing out.
I said I was so caught off guard by you
saying that I was loyal to Ethan to Like
it's literally like I I swear Chud is
the only one saying, "Oh, I just don't
care about EHD anymore. I don't want it
to stop." No one else makes that
argument. I actually I actually really
care about this drama. I'm way too
invested in this drama, actually, you
know, to be honest. So it's not it's not
even my criticism that that Nick covers
it too much. It's it's always been the
dishonesty. It's always been the fact
he's lying, you know. a fault because
we'd spoken about this topic and I
didn't realize you thought that I was a
principled a sellout. It completely
caught me off guard. I interpreted at
the time as you being upset that EHD was
a content black hole where no other
stories were getting attention and you
were holding me almost personally
responsible. So this is the Oh, you just
think I'm talking about Ethan too much.
No, it's not just that. If you were just
talking about Ethan and it was, you
know, fair, whatever. There's obviously
a criticism that I've got of Hmm, seems
like you're being very favorable towards
Ethan a lot to a fault, you know. So
when someone says your coverage of Ethan
is dishonest, Nick pretends they're
saying, "That Nicholas DeOrio guy, he
talks about Ethan Klein too much." He's
responding to a criticism that literally
nobody made and simultaneously trying to
make his detractors sound very, very
stupid. And if anyone is simply 100 IQ
enough to see through all of this,
friends or colleagues who might want to
challenge Nick on his behavior, Nick
just cuts them off, kills the
conversation entirely.
>> Guys, key update.
Nicholas DeOrio has now blocked me on
Twitter. Nicholas DeOrio has now
officially blocked me on Twitter. He's
not interested in maintaining any
friendships. He's not interested in
defending his viewpoints. He's not
interested in being an honest creator.
He's only interested in one thing,
being a yes-man.
All of these little tactics and
maneuvers that Nick Foles, those aren't
the goal. The goal was always to find a
way to become the number one Ethan Klein
ball washer.
>> Remember when this was like the worst
thing ever? Remember when all these guys
are like Ethan Klein can't take
criticism because they're posting [__]
saying you should watch this as an
alternative to his actual content. Now
we're just striking clips again. This is
Bad Empanada all over again. These guys
are total hypocrites, dude. Total
[__] hypocrites. This is insane. Did
you notice what happened there? 9 months
have passed. Nick has never meaningfully
covered the copyright strikes or the
filings for the lawsuit against Stage
Three Snark. But all of a sudden, in the
middle of one of his classic pointless
hypocrisy hunts, Nick blurts out his
actual stance on the topic and to no
one's surprise, it's just Ethan's side
of things.
>> They're posting [__] saying you should
watch this as an alternative to his
actual content. These guys are total
hypocrites, dude. This is insane. It is
insane. I thought you were waiting on
more information, Nick. The truth is
there never is more information that
Nick is waiting on. Nick isn't waiting
>> There's also just like way more mask off
moments I think even Keemstar has time
to address in this video. I'm sure we'll
go over it at some point, but Nick has
had so many mask off moments which just
shows his actual opinion.
>> For anything, he's just working.
>> Nicholas DeOrio, the Pope, is in chat.
He says the Godzilla collab is sick.
>> Aw. My Teddy Fresh order has shipped.
He's
>> Oh my god, Saint Nicholas. The most
notable example of this is Nick's
readiness to defend Ethan's lies about
Denim's chat during the CPS story.
>> Love made a a good point. You said is
this every comment? [music] I believe
this is a live feed of the chat. This is
an edited
>> What about the top right? I I thought
these were
>> No, it's
This I think when you full screen it No,
this isn't an edit. It's a cut out of
the full [music] And then he plays the
clip where Ethan explicitly tells you,
okay, that they clipped the chat and
it's like a [__] cut out of it. The
sweeping is crazy. The over the He's
legit trying to pretend that Ethan
didn't mis portray this clip, man. It's
so [__] insane. It's so insane. If
you guys need this recap, maybe you
don't know this talking point, maybe
somehow you're a new viewer or something
that's stumbled across this.
Let's take a quick look. Let's see.
Keira does lay out in pretty quick time
somewhere around here. Where does he do
it? Around here. entire chat is saying
the call CP The point is not that you
instructed yourself or anyone in her
community making contact with CPS.
[music] And I do not believe Denims made
a direct call to action to her audience
to contact CPS. Obviously, right? Okay,
so now we've moved on from this. Denims
[music] endorses this. She's directly
responsible. And the claim is now that
she essentially primed her community to
call CPS. The point is not that you
instructed your audience to contact CPS.
The point is that you propagated the
false statements that led to this
incident. You turned a blind eye to your
chat urging people to contact CPS. His
kids crawl around and eat [__] and her
whole entire chat is saying to call CPS.
In his video about the CPS call, Ethan
shows a cutout of Denims chat during her
coverage of the GRD story. The cutout
shows numerous chatters expressing
concerns about the client's kids with
some mentioning CPS. The way Ethan
presents this is as though Denims chat
was universally responding this way.
>> Notice the chat is almost [snorts] in a
complete universal agreement. Call CPS.
Call child endangerment. CPS social
services bro needs to unironically call
CPS. That's
child endangerment. Etc. Etc. I'll let
the chat play for you, but you can see
just [music] how crazy this community
is. And once again, this is Denims chat.
And it's pretty much 100% of the
comments saying call CPS on them. But
what Ethan is showing here is in fact
not 100% of the chat. This is a curated
selection of chat messages that Ethan
got from this Reddit first. In her
response, Denims did the math. And
between the first and last of the 65
messages that Ethan showed in his video,
Denims had had almost a thousand
messages sent in her chat. Meaning the
messages Ethan showed as evidence of her
entire community being whipped up into a
frenzy were only 7% of the messages sent
during her her
And I also wanted to point out that
several of the comments in that cutout,
they don't even have anything to do with
CPS and they're very similar to a lot of
messages from Ethan's own chat during
the GRD story. So, it would be pretty
dishonest to include these as evidence
of wrongdoing. Meaning the actual total
of CPS related messages in Denims chat
is even lower than this. But Ethan
doubles down on this outright false
presentation the next day.
>> I'm not exaggerating when I say
literally every comment is call CPS.
Yeah, [music] no [__] It's edited. I
don't know if Ethan knew this was an
edited selection or if he just saw
something that helped him out and didn't
bother to verify it. But he immediately
presented it as fact and used it to
bolster his side of the story. And he
tried to stand on it when he got
challenged.
>> Love made a a good point. You [music]
said is this every [snorts] comment? I
believe this is a live feed of the chat.
This isn't edited.
>> What about the top right? I I thought
these were No, it's um this [snorts] I
think when you full screen it No, this
isn't edit. It's a cutout of the full
chat. It's just enlarged over the
screen, yeah. You know what? We'll just
make it up. We'll make the whole thing
up. We'll take a picture, we'll make it
up. So, yeah, this was nowhere near her
whole chat. But even if Ethan thinks
that Denims still should have moderated
better, which I can probably agree with,
there's a pretty big difference between
a failure to moderate and being causally
responsible for any subsequent action.
Denims does have an obligation to try to
mitigate harm, but failing to fulfill
that obligation doesn't mean that she
caused the CPS call. Denims didn't cause
the call. Someone else did. So, when it
comes to responsibility, what's really
left? Well, some people claim that Bad
Empanada is notoriously bad faith or
malicious. So, Denims shouldn't have
platformed him in the first place. But I
mean, we're just getting so far away
from any true culpability here. Like,
what? Denims is responsible for the call
because she watched a video from a guy
who might be known to lie and then a
tiny portion of her chat responded to
the lies and Denims didn't delete every
single one of them and then days later
the call gets placed, which could have
been anybody, but we just assumed that
it was Denims' fault because
I don't know. Like, is this really the
standard of responsibility that we're
going to hold people to? At that point,
Denims is so detached from the action of
calling CPS itself, it doesn't really
seem fair to blame her for it. But, you
know what? Let's accept Ethan's entire
premise here. Let's say Denims is
responsible for not moderating enough
and for platforming these harmful lies
without pushing back. What are the
supposed lies? What does Ethan claim
Badempanada said that was false? So,
we'll leave that part there and return
to the DeOrio segment because I think
that is pretty much what's relevant
here. Green, yeah. They're different. I
think. Yeah. And like this is an edit.
Nick isn't waiting for anything. He's
just working.
>> Nicholas DeOrio, the Pope, is in chat.
He says the Godzilla collab is sick.
>> Aw. My Teddy Fresh order has shipped.
He's
>> Oh my god, St. Nicholas. The most
notable example of this is Nick's
readiness to defend Ethan's lies about
Denims' chat during the CPS story.
>> Love made a a good point. You said is
this every comment? I believe this is a
live feed of the chat. This was an edit.
What about the top right? I I thought
these were edited.
>> No, it's
>> [snorts]
>> this I think when you full screen it No,
this is an edit. It's a cut out of the
full chat. And then he plays the clip
where Ethan explicitly tells you, okay,
that they clipped the chat and it's like
a [__] cut out of it. chat. It's just
enlarged there. Oh, really? over the
screen, yeah. They're different. I
think. [music] Yeah. And like it's it's
it's directly explained to you in the
stream what exactly this is.
>> No, it's not. crazy? Is that not a crazy
sweep? It's directly explained to you in
the stream what it is. What does Ethan
say? It's the full chat just blowing up
on the screen. What is actually? A
filtered set of chat messages that
represent 6% of the total chat across
that time period displaying only the
absolute worst messages that support
their narrative. How do you make this
make sense? It's an edit. It's a cut out
of the full chat. And then he plays the
clip where Ethan explicitly tells you,
okay, that they clipped the chat and
it's like a [__] cut out of it.
>> Chat, it's just enlarged there.
>> Oh, really? Over the screen, yeah.
They're different. I think. Yeah. And
like it's it's it's directly explained
to you in the stream what exactly this
is. No, it's not, but it doesn't matter.
Nick isn't watching this clip to
evaluate whether it's true or form an
honest opinion. He's watching the clip
to find a way to push Ethan's [__]
and his instinct is just to adopt
whatever is being presented on screen
without really analyzing or looking into
it. I mean the Snark lawsuits and
copyright strikes, these things are key
components of Ethan Klein's narrative
over the last couple of years. Why do
you think Nick was waiting so long to
cover them?
>> So Ethan Klein, so if he goes on like an
anti-semite doxing spree, I mean that
that's got to look so bad for everyone
that promotes the [__] out of him. Nick
DiOrio, this is looking pretty bad, bro.
We love Olgy man. We [__] We [__]
love Olgy. Cover this [__] bro. Cover
this [__] Go to live Olgy. We don't
want to live stream now, bro. We don't
want to live stream. How's he going to
sweep this one up? How's Fatty going to
sweep for
You got to do something about this
tonight, man. We don't want to live
stream otherwise you're sweeping. I know
there is I know there's nothing worse
to Olgy and Nick than being accused of
sweeping. That's a heinous tackle on
their credibility equivalent sticking
a blade into their into their throat
area. Equivalent to essentially slitting
their That's that's how they feel about
it. That's the level of pain they feel
when someone says that they're using a
broom.
I haven't covered two things with Ethan
Klein, but I'll just give you kind of my
rundown with them cuz I intend to cover
them, but I'm trying to space this [__]
out
cuz it was just so much back to back.
Right, yes, of course.
>> One being the lawsuit against the Snark
subreddits. I do have a tweet about it.
I feel like I'm going to end up on the
side of being opposed at this point from
what I've seen so far.
>> [music]
>> Principally opposed
to what he's doing, but there I think
there are ways that he can win me. I
just I need to see exactly what he's
doing. I haven't watched his video about
it. I intend to do it all at once. I
think he says 2 weeks now until the
lawsuit drops.
So, we will be taking a look at that.
Nick didn't say that because he was open
to criticizing Ethan. He said it because
his friend Augie reminded him that old
commentary audiences were still
watching. And Nick I did. How crazy is
this, man? You got to do something about
this tonight, man.
This is later that day. The same day
Augie and Conor make those comments.
Again, you might notice a little bit of
a pattern here. The Nick only responds
to to pressure from other creators and
never actually does the right thing
himself. I've covered two things with
Ethan Klein, but I'll just give you kind
of my rundown with them cuz I intend to
cover them, but I'm trying to space this
[__] out
cuz it was just so much back-to-back.
Right, yes, of course.
>> One being the lawsuit against the stark
subreddits. I do have a tweet about it.
I feel like I'm going to end up on the
side of being opposed at this point from
what I've seen so far.
Principally opposed
to what he's doing, but there I think
there are ways that he can win me. I
just I need to see exactly what he's
doing. I haven't watched his video about
it. I intend to do it all at once. I
think he says 2 weeks now until the
lawsuit drops.
So, we will be taking a look at that.
Nick didn't say that because he was open
to criticizing Ethan. He said it because
his friend Augie reminded him that old
commentary audiences were still
watching. And Nick doesn't want those
people to know that he was never
actually the guy he pretends to be.
Because if he ever actually looked at
Ethan or his son honestly, by his own
principles, the foundation of his entire
channel, he would have decided [music]
against Ethan, but that's not an option.
So, instead, Nick just doesn't look.
I mean, facts. The thing about Nicholas
DeOrio though is that none of these
things are technically lies. They're
very weaselly, he's very slimy, and
intellectually dishonest, but he's not
exactly lying. The lie is Nick doing all
this stuff and then presenting himself
as principled.
>> Do you have any actual principles at
all?
>> No, none of these people have any
principles.
>> fun to be a principled streamer at this
point. His entire persona is the lie.
>> The hypocrisy hunting is going to be
extremely difficult for me to navigate
because publicly I said that if if a
reactor doesn't react to your content,
you should strike them. I said I'm
against YouTuber lawsuits for the most
part, but I do find it increasingly
difficult to care about a Twitch
streamer getting sued. The things that
we have been saying for the last 5
years, if they had just been listened to
at all and people made the slightest bit
of effort, there'd be nothing here for
Ethan to sue over.
>> This entire thing [music] is an attempt
to silence creators that he doesn't like
and to silence people he doesn't like.
Yeah, that's the best part of this is
that he scared a bunch of Redditors into
[__] themselves and shutting an
entire subreddit down. Go type in on H3
Snark and go read what they wrote about
DiOrio and tell me how much I should
feel bad for them that these little
[__] rat [__] had to sit and cry and
get scared for the night where they
thought the big mean Ethan Klein [music]
lawsuit was going to be in the mail the
next day. Wow, this guy sucks. Nobody is
asking you to feel bad for anybody. Did
you hear that? Listen to this one.
Listen to this.
>> The things that we have been saying for
the last 5 years, if they had just been
listened to at all and people made the
slightest bit of effort, there'd be
nothing here for Ethan to sue over.
>> This entire thing [music] is an attempt
to silence creators that he doesn't like
and to silence people he doesn't like.
Yeah, that's the best part of this is
that he scared a bunch of Redditors into
[__] themselves and shutting an
entire subreddit down. Go type in on H3
Snark and go read what they wrote about
DiOrio and tell me how much I should
feel bad for them that these little
[__] rat [__] had to sit and cry and
get scared for the night where they
thought the big mean Ethan Klein lawsuit
was going to be in the mail the next
day.
>> So guys
>> Wow. I would defend that free speech,
but go and see what they say about me.
Go and see how much they snark me on
this subreddit. Isn't this like the core
of free speech? I may not like what you
say, but I will defend to the death your
right to say it. Is this not the core of
free speech? The absolute core. That
even when someone is saying something
mean about you, you still defend their
right to say it. But, Nick has totally
abandoned that. And yes, some [__]
clip that we've covered before where he
says, "I'm not a free speech absolutist.
I'm a free speech enthusiast." It it
doesn't matter. It doesn't matter. It's
the same [__] bro. It's the it the same
argument applies. Because this isn't
some super hard limit of free speech. We
aren't talking about [__] child porn
or loli or whatever the [__] here. We
are talking about people talking [__]
about you and Ethan. This is within any
reasonable bounds of free speech, open
dialogue. It's within any reasonable
bounds. It doesn't matter that you're
not an absolutist. If you have any
principles surrounding free speech at
all, you should be defending this. And
obviously, your argument for not
defending something should never ever
ever ever [__] be, go look at the
[__] they say about me. Why should I?
That's insane. That is some of the most
morally bankrupt, depraved,
opportunistic [__] in the world. You are
treat You are lower than a rapist, bro.
You are lower in society than a [__]
rapist pulling [__] like that. You are
genuinely going around claiming you're
the [__] enforcer of DMCA protections
or whatever the [__] You're the enfor
You're the enforcer of free speech.
You're the John Wick of commentary. Take
You're going to take people out because
they've they've done the wrong thing on
on YouTube. And then you sweep for this.
And you And you just say, "Well, go look
at the mean things they say about me. Go
look at the mean things they say about
me. They say I run a show called Rape
Review and that I'm fat. It's slander.
Wow, this guy sucks. Nobody is asking
you to feel bad for anybody. They're
just asking if you think Ethan is doing
something wrong. But this is exactly
what Nick does. He actively runs away
from having principles. And if he were
just your average unprincipled grifter,
I mean that would be bad enough. But the
thing that really makes Nick so
contemptible is that he's also just a
total [__] loser. I mean not only is
he so sensitive that it's literally a
meme to be blocked by Nicholas Deorio on
Twitter.
>> me. I've never spoken to this man in my
life. Nick Deorio.
>> Oh, he does that. He does that, yeah.
>> I haven't But I haven't talked to him.
And not only is he this gross, cackling,
nasally weirdo,
>> Cuz that's probably what he was until
his girlfriend touched his penis.
>> Remember, weight can be lost, hair can
be grown back, but your body is ravaged
forever. Listen, [__] you got to smile
more. You know, just give them a little
bit more of a smile. That would go a
long way with the men watching.
But on top of all that stuff, he's also
a total [__] Like he admits he doesn't
know anything about politics.
>> I'm not a political [__] streamer. I
don't know anything about politics. I'm
horrible at politics. I've been
coasting. So why the [__] would anyone
ever listen to him talk about
anti-Semitism?
>> So this is an event that was Yeah, I
legit saw some [__] [__] on Twitter
say, "How's a good argument? Racism and
anti-Semitism aren't political. It's
just common sense." I'm like my mind was
blown. When when they start like it's a
[__] statement on the face of it.
But just think about the sort of debates
that Nick's wading into. The distinction
between anti-Semitism and anti-Zionism.
Um, what should be free speech and what
should be hate speech. Um,
at what point cri- cri- virulent
criticism of Israel and Israelis
actually becomes about Jews and Jewish
people uh uh the Jewish religion and
Jewish people. The- These are some of
the topics that Nick is wading into.
Those are incredibly political,
incredibly debated. He's making
statements about the [__] embassy
worker shooting the day after I have the
day it happens I'm pretty sure saying
it's an anti-semitic hate crime. He's
making that statement the day it happens
before it's even declared by anyone.
It's [__] crazy and people it's crazy
the narratives people try and spin man.
The idea that he doesn't cover politics
so that he stays out of it. He doesn't
care. Shut the [__] up. One thing by I
Bosche to platform Zog and apparently
they didn't tell Zog that like
progressive victory sent out like
America's newest lolicon. Do you not
know what Zog is? I think that's
literally the guy's name. Nick is kind
of like one of those background
characters from old high school movies.
He's like that unnamed idiot that
follows around the main idiot and like
forces out laughs at their jokes.
>> your shoes are untied.
You're so gullible McFly. I don't want
to see you in here again.
>> Okay. Like this is really all who Nick
is. He's literally this guy. Yet somehow
this very stupid, wheezing,
uncharismatic, dishonest blob of a guy
made more money in donations last year
than [__] Candace Owens. And he did
that by at some point realizing that you
can turn Ethan Good Hassan Bad into a
full-time job. But the Nicky D system
still isn't complete. Not yet.
Nick looks around. He sees Willy Mac's
channel stagnating. He sees Tech Town
get a protective order granted against
him. He sees Nux Taku get exposed for
enabling grooming. He's looking down at
which side of the aisle he's standing on
and he's panicking. So he starts
worrying that he's possibly hitched his
very large wagon to the wrong horse
face. Nick's words by the way, not mine.
And he starts laying the foundation for
the final step in his [music] system.
The step that ties the whole thing
together and the one that will allow him
to repeat the whole process again.
Distance. He sees the writing on the
wall and in classic Nick fashion he
starts planning his exit.
>> this. I hate Hassan [__] and I hate
these people more. I hate these people
so much. They're like actually [__]
insane. Dude, people will put me next to
these people because I also criticize
Hasan [__]
In the hating Hasan [__] community,
it's [__] insane. Nick can feel the
ship sinking and he's trying to make
sure he has a clean way out before he
goes down with it.
>> Yeah, this is why nobody can get held
accountable because Hasan [__] is bad.
Yeah, that is why no one gets held
accountable, Nick. That's what my video
is about. I'm glad we agree on at least
one thing, but you don't get to be the
one that points it out.
>> I'm starting to get blackpilled a little
bit. I get why people hate EHT stuff. It
has given so many people a voice who are
just like subhuman wretches. I am awake
and I can see these people. I hate them.
Right. Right. Guys, he's not like that.
What does this guy think he's fooling?
These people as if he's not one of them.
You are like them, Nick. Not because
you're a rapist or pedophile or anything
like that, but because you're a liar and
you have massively profited off of doing
the
>> And you'll take advantage of people
weaker than you when you think you get
away with it, you know.
Like a exact same thing that they are.
>> dumbest hill for Ethan to die on. Snark
clip chimping [__] I'm sorry, who
let in the Hasan [__] fan? He got hit
on the Zionist policy and I don't know
how I feel about this. On one hand, I
find it hilarious. On the other hand, I
find it hilarious. It's Zionist but with
Zionist it has three parentheses around
either side. Everyone just [__] hates
Jews now. It's insane.
>> Oh no, they blacklisted the guy who
supports terrorists. That's horrible.
It's It's almost like Twitch has finally
done something on their platform to
moderate this abhorrent behavior. Like
the levels of psychological warfare that
we've reached for  not liking
Hasan [__] Yeah, dude, we got to take
his kids away. A bunch of people use
veiled anti-Semitism to attack Jews.
Specifically people he's friends with
and in some cases I would argue him. I
don't agree with going after sponsors,
but I kind of am. Her sponsor is Hasan
[__] Okay, so by going after Hasan
[__] I'm specifically targeting her
income. Hasan [__] supports terrorists.
>> really understand what the What is the
deceptive edit here?
>> Like maybe you shouldn't make yourself
an extremely easy target while you're
attacking this person's family.
>> This is not even the first congressman
that Hasan has jokingly told his
audience to kill. And now when he starts
feeling public perception shifting ever
so slightly away from him, he does what
he's always done and he starts trying to
quietly pitter-patter away.
Okay, maybe not so quietly. This is what
he did with Bowblax. He did it with
Destiny to an extent. He'll coast off of
popular sentiment for as long as he can
and only when things get too hot will he
then turn his back and pretend like he
was principled.
>> I'm a [__]
I'm a [__] whole time.
>> people say that you're sweeping or
you're doing this
I've literally taken about seven of my
friends and former associates out back
and put a bullet in the back of their
head. So, I really don't care.
Uh I've literally executed half this
[__] space. So, And one day Nick will
do this to Ethan, too. The public
pressure will get to be too much.
They'll find a new audience to leech
from and he'll drop H3 and pretend he
had a good reason for it. And when that
happens, Ethan will realize that he was
actually right about Nick several years
ago.
>> Yeah, this is what I mean. You argue
with people on the internet and you get
charged up and you've got to realize
that you're probably talking to someone
that looks like this.
And what I mean by that is a
pimply-faced kid who, you know, what
he's just he's a know-nothing. Like if I
met this kid in real life, I would
literally just You wouldn't think twice
about him. Couldn't have said it better
myself. But until then, Nick is going to
do what he always does. He'll take his
earnings and then he'll try to scurry
away from the consequences of what he
had to do to get them. Kind of like a
rodent. A very, very large rodent.
>> Wesley, what about the R.O.U.S.es?
Rodents of unusual size?
I don't think they exist.
>> [groaning]
>> Nick Lisciandro gets the Rodent of
Unusual Size award.
Okay.
Great stuff. Great stuff.
Really awesome stuff. I think total rape
on the Oreo that segment. I don't see a
way around that. Especially with the
actual bits that I've just just added. I
don't really see a way around that. And
I invite anyone to try and figure a way
around that.